for drivers races can be won or lost in  the mind using neuroscience the team at  ford have found a way to help drivers  better understand their minds and choose  to win  [Music]  it started with a question  exactly how in the zone is a driver when  competing ford's team of engineers and  scientists designed a helmet system that  reads driver's brain activity using eeg  when they compete the helmet measures  alpha brain waves research shows alpha  waves between 8 to 12 hertz relate to  top performance  the helmet data trains an artificial  intelligence model to recognize when  drivers are in a deep state of focus  through factors such as sustained  attention engagement and error combining  helmet and gps data allows drivers to  understand where to lift their  performance for sections of the rally  stage or circuit that need greater  concentration ford's new helmet helps  drivers control their mind improve their  performance and perhaps bring them  closer to a win